jean provoque tout loket man l'un porte
sur une imposante galerie de personnages
plus ou moins recommandables des hommes
d'affaires des avocats et quelques
responsables politiques aux etats unis
et en russie
ex directeur du fbi haye a été chargé en
mai 2010 est d'établir si l'équipe de
campagne du milliardaire donald trump
s'est concerté avec moscou pour
influencer les résultats de l'élection
présidentielle de 2016
et si oui pour quelles raisons et avec
quelle contrepartie mail enquête a
débuté bien avant dès juillet 2016 le
fbi ya sous la direction de james kumi
entamait une enquête sur l' ingérence
présumée de la russie dans la corbeille
c'est la publication par wikileaks de
dizaines de milliers de courriels
provenant de la campagne de la démocrate
hillary clinton qui avait alerté les
autorités
on apprendra par la suite que l'équipe
de campagne de donald trump étaient bien
informés de ce piratage
un des moments clés de cette partie de
poker se passe en juin 2016 ou le coup
de campagnes de donald trump dans la
tour du milliardaire à new york
sur place le fils aîné du candidat dans
leurs 30 juniors son gendre devenu
conseiller jared kushner et le directeur
de campagne
paul mara ford ils sont venus rencontrer
une avocate à la réputation sulfureuse
natalia vaisselle niscayah qui dit
représenter le kremlin l'équipe trempe
s'attend à obtenir des informations
susceptibles de nuire au camp de leurs
adversaires et le riz clinton
parmi les questions des enquêteurs
comment ces présumés informations sur
clinton aurait-elle pu être obtenue de
façon légale par les russes et pourquoi
voudrait-il les offrir à son adversaire
trump
cinq mois plus tard le 8 novembre 2016
dans notre homme est élu président au
cours des semaines suivantes
l'administration obama impose une série
de sanctions contre les agences de
renseignement russes et excuses 35
diplomates russes du territoire
américain
les services secrets américains ont
acquis la certitude que le câble est et
derrière les piratage de courriels et
d'autres un gérant ce informatique russe
qui avait pour but de transformer la
campagne d'hillary clinton en châteaux
de cartes
pendant cette période de transition
politique
le futur conseiller à la sécurité
nationale de temps de l'europe
le militaire mike loughlin s'entretient
à plusieurs reprises avec l'ambassadeur
russe à washington sergueï kisliak il
cherche à limiter les conséquences des
nouvelles sanctions américaines
dans l'autre groupe n'est pas encore à
la maison blanche et son conseiller et
c'est déjà de rebrasser les cartes sur
la scène internationale mike loughlin
sera rapidement sacrifié après
l'assermentation de trump il plaide
coupable d'avoir menti web bail et
acceptent de collaborer avec les
enquêteurs
en mars 2010 est le directeur du fbi et
james cromitie met cartes sur table il
confirme publiquement l'existence d'une
enquête de ses services de
contre-espionnage sur l'ingérence russe
dans la campagne de 2007
en mai 2010 est le président trump
congédie james commis toujours en mai
2010 est le ministre de la justice de
l'époque jeff sessions se récuse de
toute enquête sur la campagne électorale
de 2016 et admet avoir rencontré
l'ambassadeur russe à washington à deux
reprises son adjoint robert rosin steen
nomme euros bruts muller procureur
spécial et lui donne le mandat de mener
une enquête approfondie sur l'ingérence
russe dans la campagne présidentielle
rapidement robert fowler et son équipe
épingle le fidèle collaborateur et
conseiller juridique de dans notre hub
l'avocat mike cohen
il plaide coupable à des accusations de
violations des comptes de campagne
d'évasion fiscale et de fraude bancaire
l'acceptent de collaborer avec
l'équipement l'heure
au même moment l'organisateur en chef de
la campagne électorale de donald trump
parle mana ford est jugé coupable de
diverses malversations financières liées
à des oligarques russes et des groupes
pour russe en ukraine
il est incarcéré il accepte lui aussi de
collaborer à l'enquêté du procureur
spécial mais il est ensuite accusé
d'avoir menti aux enquêteurs
malgré son accord de coopération janvier
2019 un autre personnage louche de
l'entourage de dans l'autre up est
arrêté par le fbi à rogers tonnes
admirateurs et ancien collaborateur de
reach nexus et de ronald reagan fait
face à sept chefs d'accusation le
reliant à la publication par wikileaks
des milliers de courriels nuisibles
aucun démocrate stone est accusé entre
autres d' obstruction à la justice de
faux témoignages et de subornation de
témoin il a plaidé non coupable et
refuse de collaborer avec l'équipement
nous avons nettement améliorée en
janvier 2019
l'avocat de dans les trois amigos julian
y affirme dans une de ses multiples
entrevues télévisées que les discussions
sur un projet de tour trump à moscou ce
sont sans doute poursuivi jusqu'à
l'élection de novembre 2016 le lent mais
donald trump s'empresse d'affirmer le
contraire
l'enquète maulin amorcée par le fbi a
permis d'inculper à ce jour plus d'une
trentaine de personnes parmi lesquels 13
russe et quelques-unes de leurs
entreprises
parmi les américains arrêtés quatre
figures dominantes ont accepté de
collaborer
une grande question demeure à ce jour
robert mueller est il en mesure de
présenter une preuve irréfutable de
collusion entre les collaborateurs de
dans l'autre up et les russes
ici oui jusqu'à quel point d'altran lui
même et est il impliqué dans cette
grande partie